uh how you boys been good
oh my god what
do you do
with a little more enthusiasm how are
you guys doing how's yours have you been
conor have you been how you been i'll be
your therapist for this week thank you
how are you feeling i i feel like you
need a therapist joey because i feel
like you've uh you've almost been
canceled again on twitter for saying
more hot taste it's gonna be the weekly
thing or just like review like possible
cancellation of the week cancellation
and today on the chopping block today i
just i just found it funny that uh after
all this time you actually go out your
way to watch anime again i think one
time i tweet about anime
joey
joey has the first anime take in like
what like six months and then uh what
was the take
[Music]
remind me okay okay so
let me let me bring you up to speed
right because this is a multi-layered
check okay okay this is like a
multi-layered meme multiple angles to
cancel okay so it started off the the
layer first starts at the caisson
episode right that which is of us
recording it just went up right and yeah
you know thankfully a lot of people
loved it it was a great episode right
yeah but on one segment of that show and
there's a highlight clip of it uh is
where we talk about the jews of kaisen
anime yeah i think it's because we were
talking to caisson about like what anime
she's watched recently or something like
that
weeks ago for us um and so i was like
you know
after me finally having seen it
you know a while back i was like oh oh
you know i think this might be perfect
time right now since we're already
talking about the animator you know kind
of go into it a little bit talk about it
right give our thoughts on it yeah how
hot takes if you will yeah uh and my hot
take of dudes to kaisen was me saying i
thought it was okay
and uh and then followed by i just
preferred demon slayer yeah
that's a show right and there's a
[ __ ] high likelihood i mean you are a
clown for that opinion i gotta admit
maybe i don't know a new season though
it's kind of tough right right maybe
yeah yeah yeah okay at the time of
recording that was clown take but now
okay maybe not i mean it was a clown
take though because it's literally
because in the clip i'm pretty sure i
said something along the lines of just
the kaisen had everything that you know
i thought i was going to like but for
summer whatever it was i can't even give
like a uh like a proper
viable like you know
reason for it yeah to just say that for
some reason it just didn't really click
in my head yeah never did i say that the
show was like mid or that the show was
bad in any way i just said i thought it
was okay yeah yeah twitter
when
ballistic over that
there were like a couple of people
how how ballistic we talking i mean a
few angry people or like i mean yeah i
mean you know twitter does what's what
it does best right it gets [ __ ] you
know just overblows everything out of
proportion but like i even had a couple
of people tweeting at me like videos
from like small and youtubers being like
joe you're getting cancelled and i'm
like oh god what now
is it for something i liked on twitter i
don't know and i went to look at it and
it was like joey's hottest take on jews
and kaisen and on the thumbnail it just
says he thought it was okay and i was
like oh my god i can't even call a show
okay anymore without being cancelled
like what the [ __ ] is this and then so
that's layer one yeah okay okay layer
two is when i started watching
demonstration season two recently right
and i made a tweet you know first tweet
in six months about anime where i say
something along the lines of i started
watching season two of demon slayer
happy to say zany is still the worst
character in the show
all the zenitsu fans went ballistic
right as they do of course they do as
they do you know calling your best boy
they stand up wearing those diapers yeah
and then and then but
but then some people took it back to
that you know recent [ __ ] clip of me
talking about jesus christ and saying
that demons better than jesus christ and
they had the audacity to be like oh now
he's backpedaling
now he's backpedaling now he said he he
hyped up demon slayer so much even
comparing it to jesus christ and saying
it was better than jesus christ and now
he's saying that oh it's it's the demon
slayer is not a good show which i never
said
mind you i just said zenny to [ __ ]
sucks because he does
right he does and it's like and it's
like if anything i'm [ __ ] enjoying
season two right now season two has been
great i feel season two's like kind of
brought back the hype for demon slayer
for a lot of y'all right i wasn't that
hype but season two is made yeah
definitely like the like the movie you
know as moon oh god is this gonna be
another [ __ ] hot take as as okay as i
thought the movie was
no okay okay i'll agree with you i
thought the season two has blown the
movie yeah out of the way
because like i recently just finished my
anime with the you know man made of the
year video i feel like anime has gotten
so much better now that just saying
something is okay
is now detrimental to the anime right
right it's not even bad anymore yeah
like calling something mid is an insult
and someone calling something okay is an
insult i feel like it's a copy pastor
now where everyone is like attack on
titan is mid it's basically a copyright
right like everyone everyone that keeps
saying that exact phrase yeah not no
elaboration no attack on titan is mid
because it's such an easy bait yeah it
is
it's literally fake but everyone does it
but the thing is i didn't even say jesus
and kaisen is okay for bait i just
legitimately think it's just okay
i really like jesus christ yeah and and
that's fine right like there were parts
of jesus christ and i really enjoyed but
i don't i personally didn't enjoy it as
much as other people or as i thought i
was going to well do you feel like
saying something is okay or mid is even
more of an insult than saying something
is bad nowadays because i feel like
maybe i i feel like i've just like
at least in like discussing shows or
anime or whatever or manga i feel like
you you don't see as many people just
saying something is straight up bad
anymore people just say oh it's mid it's
just mid okay like i get i get the word
mid mid is insulting yeah yeah admit is
so little effort to articulate how you
feel about a show you can't even you
can't even like
get the energy to even describe what you
don't like about it
i feel like
the the word average when talking about
a show there's like there's like a
a a contention between like okay being
like you know taking more in a positive
way yeah and then mid being taken in
like a negative way right but they both
mean the same thing technically speaking
mid is just short for middle
which is okay
neither good or bad just okay right but
like i feel now people take the word
okay
and put like a negative spin on it which
yeah
it's like if if uh
let's say uh
you had a wedding right yeah and you're
like mom did you like the wedding she's
like it's okay
i would be annoyed i would be like what
do you mean my wedding was just i
invited you i put on a spread right but
i feel like okay but i feel it's always
free but i feel but i feel it's kind of
on you to compare your own wedding to
juice
how strongly i feel about my best friend
okay
i was like how did we get from jiu-jitsu
guys into our wedding because i'm just
i'm just thinking like let's just say
you are you you put your heart and soul
out of the sub that you like yeah yeah
okay
i'm gonna go to sydney today and be like
sydney i know we're getting married this
year but like justin tyson right i mean
it's it's kind of it's kind of more
important
i pulled my heart into jiu jitsu i said
more than i did the wedding i hope so i
know there's someone out there that
would say that i hope somebody asked me
how was god's wedding because i know
what i'm gonna say
i feel like he pulled his heart more
into a demon slur you know honestly i
wasn't passionate about that
yeah i don't know just so so my uh my my
advice to all of you who perhaps want to
share your opinion about anime don't use
the word okay from now on it can get you
canceled